ich heiße steve kaufmann ich bin der
gründer von link lng community für
sprachen lernen
heute werde ich auf deutsch sprechen und
ich werde also meine erfahrung oder
meine der über sprache nehmen erzählen
und besonders mit beziehungen zu meiner
erfahrung mit deutsch mit der deutschen
in deutscher sprache
meine eltern stammen aus der
tschechoslowakei
ich bin in schweden geboren als ich fünf
jahre alt sind der nach kanada gezogen
also meine eltern sprach immer deutsch
miteinander zu hause aber mit uns mit
meinem bruder und ich immer englisch
also sprache lernen für mich und ich
darf sagen dass ich könnte mehr oder
weniger gut 12 wurde tyson sprache
sprachen lernen
hängt davon ab wie viel motivation wir
haben also das glaube ich ist das
wichtigste
der wichtigste faktor
zweitens wie viel zeit wir bringen zum
mit mit der sprache und drittens müssen
wir also wer also wie sagt man also
fähigkeit aufmerksam zu werden also
aufmerksamkeit ist sehr sehr wichtig
aber die wichtigste das ist motivation
und als wir jung waren
mein oder dich den worten nicht deutsch
lernen weil wir erst das ist oft so wie
man kanada wir wollten kanadisch sein
wird nur englisch sprechen und wir waren
das war es gab eine resistenz gegen also
zum beispiel deutsch
wir haben französischen die schule
gelernt aber auch dort das wir könnten
nicht französisch sprechen dann in als
ich 19 jahre war möchte ich ich wollte
nach europa fahren
ich bin auf der
hafen- und er gern dann habe ich
versucht arbeit zu finden auf irgendeine
schiff da und ich habe ein platz auf ein
deutsches schiff gefunden konnte und
dann habe ich durch also über dem ozean
mit diese deutsche schiff gefahren und
dann dort habe ich erst einmal versucht
ein bisschen deutsch zu sprechen ich
hatte ich erinnere ich mich hätte ein
buch ich habe versucht all diese
änderungen der den dem des alles zu
lernen es war sehr schlimm sehr schwer
schwierig dann habe ich ganz viel
autostopp in europa gemacht und manchmal
auch in deutschland und ab und zu habe
ich auch ein bisschen deutsch gesprochen
aber dass das war sehr sehr begrenzt ich
war drei jahre in frankreich habe dort
studiert nachher weiß also was
kanadische diplomat weiter in hongkong
dort habe ich chinesisch studiert
nachher war
aber ich in japan und da dort habe ich
selbst japanisch gewärmt und nachher
habe ich seit 47 arbeite ich in die und
internationale holzgeschäft 87 als ich
ich habe meine diese firma gearbeitet
habe verlasst abschiede und ich hätte
ein monat
zwischen job und ich dann beschloss ich
ich habe entscheiden ich werde deutsch
lernen und dann habe ich besucht alle
die second hand bekommen und ich habe
sehr viele bücher gefunden
das erste jahr und alle diese bücher
hätten wort schätze und deswegen könnte
ich lesen obwohl es gab sehr viel würde
dich nicht könnte und ich gebe nicht
alle zeigen aber ich habe also eine eine
große menge und ich habe während
einwohner habe ich sehr viel gelöst und
auch gehört weil ich habe sehr schöne
kassetten gefunden
gewöhnlich gespräche zwischen
gewöhnliche leute alltägliche gespräche
und das war auch sehr schön
obwohl immer es gab sehr viele wörter
die ich nicht könnte aber ich war ich
hatte dann die motivation ich wollte das
lernen und nachher habe ich auch in
sprachen lernen
ich finde das ist sehr wichtig dass man
sofort wie möglich von dieser partie wie
zielle texten zum authentischen texten
übergeht war diese sind interessant weil
deswegen dadurch kann man nicht nur der
die sprache lernen sondern auch sehr
viel über dieser kultur dieser land und
und so weiter und das habe ich auch
gemacht und ich habe sehr viele bücher
weil ich interessiere mich sehr viel im
geschichte unser und dann hier in dieser
bücher kennen sie sehen es gibt sehr
viele wörter die ich nicht kenne und das
ist nicht nur der beispiel mit deutsch
aber auch mit spanisch oder französisch
nicht französisch geht es ganz gut
und deswegen haben wir diese link system
entwickelt weil es vereinfacht dieser
prozess
viel zu lesen und zu hören und die
vokabeln zu akkumulieren
ja und ich finde das sprachenlernen in
die schule
ich weiß in deutschland ist es viel
effektiver als in kanada in kanada die
meistens englisch sprechender leute die
machen zehn jahre französischen die
schule und kann gar kein französisch in
deutschland ich bin immer also imponiert
imponiert dass sehr viele leute sehr gut
englisch sprechen
deswegen glaube ich die schule sind
effektiver aus
ich weiß auch ich war einmal in
düsseldorf es gab eine konferenz
sprachen und beruf und ich habe einige
mittel mitgeteilt und dann die meisten
leute die ihn in ihre firmen englisch
studieren oder einer sprach italienisch
oder spanisch
sie machen gefahr ein oder zwei stunden
pro woche und dann vielleicht vielleicht
ein stunde selbst studieren aber das ist
das ist nicht das ist nichts wenn ich
eine sprache für deere und die letzten
zehn jahre habe ich russisch tschechisch
polnisch rumänisch portugiesisch
studiert dann muss ich jeden tag etwas
tun
und naja
mache sehr viel also ich höre
hauptsächlich weil es sein tag zu machen
ich kann das im auto wenn ich die die
revanche oder oder etwas etwas machen
kann ich immer höre deswegen ich finde
dass heute mit der internet mit die
mp3-player oder alles was man auch
internet finden kann nicht nur
gesellschafter wie zum beispiel link
aber sehr viel inhalte interessante
inhalte zum beispiel ich ich ich wollte
mich ein bisschen meine mein deutsch
erfrischend mal ich habe mich an meinen
eine mine eigene firma gegründet in 87
im holzgeschäft und dann in der
beginnenden 19 neunziger jahre haben wir
auch ganz viel geschäft in deutschland
gemacht wir haben verkauft aber wir
haben auch als in deutschland gekauft
und verkauft nach japan
und diese zeit habe ich ganz viel
deutsch gesprochen aber seitdem habe ich
sehr sehr wenig deutsch gesprochen und
es werden die letzte woche weil ich ich
wollte mich an dich hin vorbereiten habe
ich also sehr tolle also podcast
gefunden
es gibt eine website poster.de und dann
es gibt sehr schöne podcasts über
verschiedene themen bei uns link zum
beispiel einige unserer mitglieder haben
sehr interessante podcast auf deutsch
gefunden und sie haben das alles
transkribiert und dann haben wir bei uns
war bei uns in link in die bibliothek
gibt es immer wie auch das audio und die
texte und das ist sehr wichtig und dann
haben wir eine masse also funktionen
hilft uns die vokabeln zu akku leer war
für mich ist das ist das wichtige
wichtigste nicht die grammatik also ich
kann das nicht ich mache sehr viel fehle
ich weiß das aber wenn ich sehe diese
diese diese tabellen der der demda ich
kann das geht nicht rein
es geht nicht rein aber wenn ich sehr
viel lese und höre dank allmählich wird
es ein bisschen man wird gewöhnt weil
sprache lernen dass es ihn gewollt dass
seine eine gewohnheit glaube ich und der
passport ist dann sagen ja und weil ich
habe sehr viel fragt sprachen gelernt
ich wollte sagen weil wenn man hat keine
vokabeln
obwohl man beherrscht ich glaube nicht
man kann das grammatik beherrschen ohne
sehr viel erfahrung mit die mit der
sprache zu haben weil die dramatische
erklärungen und tabellen das muss eine
beziehung haben nicht etwas das schon
ist eine dass man schon erkennt deswegen
finden für mich ist das wichtigste
sehr viel zu hören und zu lesen und
eventuell zu sprechen
und ab und zu man kann auf die
dramatische helden an buben und und
jetzt ist es so dass mit der internet
ich kann immer nur also german nahm den
menschen dann kriege ich sofort diese
tabelle da kann ich ein bisschen
angucken aber ich werde das nicht es ist
nicht möglich dass ich werde das alles
beherrschen es geht nicht dass das weckt
ein bisschen meine aufmerksamkeit und
dann die nächste mal wenn ich lese und
höre dass vielleicht werde ich bemerken
und versuche ich versuche das zu tun
in dem in der oder oder durch das ist
wichtig und deswegen habe ich immer sehr
viel interesse schlese dinge die für
mich interessant sind und ich kann auch
zum beispiel ich habe diese hörbuch
gekauft gehörte der mann von 50 jahren
ich habe das buch und ich kann auch die
texte dass der text auf internet
befinden und dann kann ich importieren
nach links und alle diese wörter die ich
nicht kenne
da kann ich nachschlagen und hören und
lesen und das eeg als ich in deutschland
die letzte mal war habe ich habe ich
diese buch gekauft war das für ein thema
in deutschland
und obwohl es gibt sehr viele wörter die
ich nicht kenne ich kann mehr oder
weniger verstehen und alles diese weg
mein interesse unter holt mein interesse
und allmählich wird diese neue sprache
eingang einer gewohnheit und so wird es
wird man immer immer besser und ich
glaube wenn man sie wie diese sprache
unterrichtet in die firmen zwei stunden
woche und eine vielleicht eine studie
das ist das ist nicht genug das nicht
genug
aber ich habe diese erfahrung ich weiß
wie man das macht weil ich habe das
ganze zu 30-mal immer und ich glaube
vielleicht viele leute die sind zu
passiv
sie geht in der unterricht sie hören
leere sagte muss das machen das machen
zum beispiel ich mache nie die übungen
weil das ist so so schlimm das ist so
uninteressant
ich bevorzuge zum beispiel nur die
antworten zu sehen nicht die übungen die
ich werde nie die diese antwort
besprengen mich besuchen zu zu
wdr.de wieder die korrekte antwort zu
geben dass nach wenig ich habe immer
spaß meine sprache nehmen und es läuft
besser okay das ist genug ich wünsche
ihnen sehr viel spaß am sprachen lernen
und vielen dank vielen dank zum
aufmerksamkeit da gewesen